il est président du MoDem maire de Pau
et il sera d'ailleurs tout à l'heure à
l'Élysée pour la rencontre du chef de
l'État avec les mers
[Musique]
bonjour François Valéron bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être là ce matin la nuit a
été plutôt calme 72 interpellations
d'après le ministère de l'Intérieur il y
en avait jusqu'à 1300 dans les nuits les
plus violentes hier soir le chef de
l'État Emmanuel Macron s'est rendu au
côté des forces de l'ordre dans une
quinzaine du 17e arrondissement entre
autres depuis quelques jours son
entourage dit qu'il veut prendre le
temps avant de prendre des décisions
pour la suite l'état du pays permet-il
de prendre le temps selon vous
en ce moment ça me paraît la logique
on a eu une de ces crispations violentes
qui
arrivent fréquemment dans la société
française
c'est une crise passion qu'il faut
essayer de de décrypter de comprendre ce
qui s'est passé réellement
et c'est pas simple comme vous le savez
sur votre antenne c'est ce sera l'enjeu
aussi la rencontre à laquelle vous
participerez tout à l'heure avec les
maires ont été visés avec les maires dès
que des villes qui ont été visées et ça
sera évidemment une partie des une
partie des interrogations et il faut
trouver des réponses adaptées ou
peut-être mieux adaptés que beaucoup des
réponses qu'on a trouvées depuis des
décennies sur ces la réponse aujourd'hui
elle est sécuritaire elle est politique
elle est les deux à la fois où est-ce
que vous placez le curseur je pense
qu'elle est
sécuritaire c'est évident on est dans
une dans une société
qui exprime un besoin d'ordre un besoin
de prise en charge
nous azimut j'étais très frappé il y
avait cette petite manifestation qui
avait été demandé par l'Association des
Maires hier devant les mairies et à
Pouille avait sans mot d'ordre sans
appel d'aucune sorte il y avait
plusieurs centaines de personnes de 100
300 personnes qui sont venues
spontanément et parmi eux il y avait pas
mal de parents des cités
parce qu'ils sont en première ligne
d'événements que non seulement il
n'approuve pas mais qu'il redoute
qu'il redoute parce que c'est leur
quartier il y a eu un
jugement une déclaration d'un
responsable de d'association de quartier
qui a dit notre quartier ne mérite pas
ça
c'est la première chose deuxièmement il
redoute pour leurs enfants quand vous
avez des enfants qui ont 10 ou 12 ans ou
13 ans vous voyez la fascination que la
bande la violence
peut exercer sur eux
j'étais très très frappé il y a eu des
il y a eu comme dans toutes les villes
qui ont eu les mêmes incidents chez nous
les incidents ont été
pas horrible mais il y a que
des barricades enflammés dans les rues
des voitures enflammées et une un groupe
d'une cinquantaine qui a essayé de
mettre le feu à la nouvelle annexe du
commissariat que nous venions de
construire mais est-ce que vous vous
avez craint ou est-ce que vous craignez
pour votre sécurité pour celle de notre
famille quand on voit comme ce week-end
l'attaque du domicile du maire de
L'Haÿ-les-Roses ça a beaucoup marqué les
esprits non pour vous ça a beaucoup
marqué des esprits moi je n'ai jamais
ressenti
un risque de cet ordre de on a la chance
de vivre dans une ville où les liens
sont très puissants entre habitants
entre voisins entre communautés entre
élus et population
je n'ai jamais eu ce genre de crainte
mais
les parents qui vivent cela des familles
qui vivent cela ont ce genre de crainte
et essayer de comprendre et puis il y a
eu des arrestations j'étais en train de
vous dire
et c'est intéressant parce que les
déclarations à la barre de ceux qui sont
passés ou en tout cas ont été examinés
devant le tribunal
dans une grève greffée donc on n'a pas
pu aller au bout de mais ils ont été
entendus en comparution immédiate et ils
ont dit deux ou trois choses qui sont
intéressantes à réfléchir ils ont dit
Naël on s'en fiche un peu on le
connaissait pas du prénom de ce jeune
qui a été tué donc la semaine c'est pas
c'est pas notre affaire
mais ce qui est apparu c'est que il
trouvait dans ces incidents et dans ces
événements
quelque chose qui était intéressant à
vivre qui était qui donnait qui donnait
du sel à la vie
ce qui prouve que il y a une de mes
fondamentale un certain nombre de ceux
qui vivent ou qui créent ces incidents
en réalité
c'est leur vie qui ne qui ne les
intéressent pas mais là ça relève de
quoi il y a quelques mois intérieur
avait été critiqué pour avoir dit il y a
un en sauvagement de notre société le
chef de l'État avait dit dessiver les
escient certains à l'extrême droite
disent on est au bord de la guerre
civile un syndicat de police alliances
avec une sapolis a dit nous sommes en
guerre quel mot vous vous mettriez sur
ce que l'on est en train de vivre et la
réalité que vous décrivez alors le mot
en sauvagement ça fait 30 ans qu'il est
dans la probabilité que française c'est
Jean-Pierre Chevènement qui l'avait
qu'il avait mis
il y a parlé des sauvages en effet je
trouve que des civilisations le mot
était très était très justement choisi
c'est quoi les valeurs qui nous
permettent de vivre ensemble
pour un certain nombre de ces jeunes
quand ils sont jeunes
c'est cela qui ne joue plus son rôle
c'est plus un repère donc ça veut dire
qu'ils ne font plus sociétés mais ça
fait longtemps que ça dure en vérité et
donc ça m'amène à une conclusion
aujourd'hui c'est pas seulement dans le
béton qu'il faut trouver des qu'il faut
trouver des réponses de rénovation
urbaine c'est pas ça n'est plus
seulement alors je dis ça peut-être que
comme mère d'une ville qui a beaucoup
rénové les quartiers qui sont maintenant
je crois un exemple y compris de
national
mais ça n'est plus dans le béton ça
n'est plus dans les gros investissements
par millions c'est dans la prise en
charge des jeunes des personnes des
jeunes filles et des jeunes garçons vous
parliez à l'instant des parents
arrêtons-nous en instance sur cette
question parce que c'est l'une des
questions du débat aujourd'hui cette
nuit le chef de l'État dans des propos
qui sont rapportés par nos confrères du
Parisien ce matin lorsqu'ils se rend aux
côtés des forces de l'ordre qu'il
échangent avec elle il a ses mots que je
vais vous citer il faudrait que la
première infraction on arrive à
sanctionner financièrement et facilement
les familles une sorte de tarif minimum
dès la première connerie hier à votre
disait revenons à la possibilité de
priver les familles d'allocations
familiales est-ce que c'est un sillon
qu'il faut creuser
ça n'est pas la même chose c'est pas ce
sont deux déclarations qui n'ont pas le
même sens est-ce qu'il faut qu'il y ait
sanction et sanctions immédiate chaque
fois qu'il y a un dérapage la réponse
est oui
évidemment lorsqu'il s'agit de jeunes
enfants la sanction s'adresse aux
familles les allocations familiales
c'est autre chose qui sont les parents
et en vérité qui sont souvent les mers
seuls qui élèvent des enfants dans ces
quartiers
je ne crois pas que la
seule réponse soit de les priver d'une
partie de leur des revenus minimum qui
les font vivre quel type de sanctions
imaginez-vous
amandes immédiate ça c'est une sanction
un monde immédiate s'adressant aux
familles c'est ce que a évoqué le
président de la République mais
voyez bien de bien il y a une demande de
la société française qui est de pris une
demande forte qui est de prise en charge
de la responsabilité de l'ordre dans la
rue
au fond c'est ce que veut dire cette
cagnotte si problématique et si enfin
qui pose des tas de questions vous
parlez de la cagnotte un million 300000
en soutien en policier soupçonné d'avoir
tué le jeune âge donc ce que ça signifie
c'est une partie des Français considère
que
l'ordre doit passer avant tout vous
dites une cagnotte problématique parce
que vous ne la soutenez pas vous ne
donniez pas vous voyez bien que que
un drame de cet ordre ne devrait pas
donner lieu à bénéfice
et donc tient à la famille du policier
si on si on l'explique de cette manière
là
ça devrait pas entraîner à un bénéfice
et je suis sûr que le policier lui-même
qui est l'auteur de ce drame je suis sûr
qu'il est lui-même gêné lui-même
c'est pas ce qu'il voulait alors il
reste à la justice à la police à
comprendre ce qui se passe
mais le sens de ce que signifie ces
multiples dont
ça signifie nous on veut être du côté de
ceux qui nous défendent il y a une
partie de la population qui soutient les
policiers
est-ce qu'on peut imaginer ce qu'est le
travail quotidien d'un policier dans les
quartiers les plus difficiles quand tu
arrives des moments les plus difficiles
différents entre soutenir la police et
soutenir le policier de l'auteur du tir
contre je dis ça ne devrait pas donner
lui à bénéfice et tout le monde le
comprend bien mais ce que ces Français
qui ont participé ce qu'ils expriment
c'est un besoin et c'est un besoin de
solidarité avec ceux qui les défendent
et vous voyez bien que le
la mise en cause perpétuelle de
des policiers de leur pensée de leurs
arrières pensées des accusations de
racisme tout ça bouleverse une grande
partie des Français et c'est d'ailleurs
assez drôle parce que parmi les
mouvements qui les accusent ainsi il y a
des élus le maire de Lyon vous
connaissez son orientation politique en
écologiste le maire de Lyon
avec un mouvement qui souvent mais en
cause les policiers le maire de Lyon il
a des incidents que dit-il il dit il
nous faut plus de force de police il y a
pas assez de force de police et vous
voyez l'incroyable paradoxe dans lequel
on se trouve il y a une demande d'ordre
en effet vous avez raison je voudrais
juste revenir aussi sur la question de
l'éducation François Bayrou c'est assez
symptomatique le préfet de l'Hérault
umutum a eu des mots qui peuvent
paraître presque d'une certaine banalité
quand il dit si vous attrapez votre
gamin qu'il est pris en train de brûler
des véhicules de police caillasser des
pompiers au piller des magasins la
méthode c'est quoi ces deux claques et
au lit dit-il c'est une formule mais
c'est aussi une conception de
l'éducation on lui est tombé dessus il
est critiqué pour ça est-ce que vous
dit-il à raison la bonne méthode c'est
de claquer au lit franchement moi c'est
une déclaration que je peux pas
critiquer parce que il m'est arrivé dans
ma vie de d'être confronté à des moments
comme ça il vous est arrivé en pleine
campagne électorale en 2002 de gifler un
jeune homme qui vous allez poches oui il
y a
être un parent un père de famille
être responsable d'enfant ça veut dire
que oui vous imposez enfin vous devez
imposer à ces enfants le respect de
choses élémentaires alors je défends pas
du tout
ni les claques ni les fessées mais je
défends l'autorité des parents je disais
l'ordre
des policiers mais il y a aussi l'ordre
des parents il y a aussi l'autorité et
c'est une autorité qui souvent dans les
quartiers a disparu
pourquoi alors c'est compliqué j'ai des
souvenirs de cette époque de cet
incident dont nous parlons en 2002 donc
pendant votre campagne cet incident dont
nous parlons
j'ai reçu à l'époque 10.000 lettres
je sais pas si vous rendez compte et
c'était à l'époque où c'était pas des
messages à la poste Internet
dans lesquels les parents souvent des
parents
d'origine immigré souvent des parents
des quartiers disaient
monsieur vous avez vraiment bien fait de
faire ça mais nous on nous interdit de
le faire et on comprend très bien que
entre la violence
l'éducation c'est pas de la violence
c'est pas terrifié c'est pas frappé
et un geste éducateur vous voyez bien
qu'il y a des différences et vous voyez
bien que le fait de remettre on a vu une
vidéo qui a beaucoup tourné sur les
écrans c'est à père de famille qui vient
chercher son enfant qui est dans ses
dans ses mouvements et dans ces
manifestations il le prend il le met
dans le coffre de la voiture c'était
évidemment pas le l'idée de le mettre
dans le coffre c'est évidemment l'idée
de dire écoute tu reviens et on fait
comme ça alors
vous voyez bien que toutes ces lorsque
le président de la République dit faut
prendre son temps
c'est à ça qu'on pense est-ce qu'il y a
des réponses d'éducation et même de
rééducation pour ceux qui sont entraînés
dans ces dérives là vous avez entendu ça
aussi qui disent François balrouilles il
y a une forme de désœuvrement alors
c'est une coïncidence mais il y a une
semaine le président de la République
avant tous les essences avait posé la
question par exemple du calendrier
scolaire en disant il y a des jeunes qui
deux mois et demi de l'année là on est
en plein dedans dans l'été ne sont pas à
l'école parce que l'école s'arrête il
faut revoir tout ça vous avez été en
charge de l'éducation c'est un sujet que
vous connaissez par cœur est-ce que
galop une réponse ou elle peut vous dire
pas de lien à faire c'est compliqué la
première chose qu'il faudrait faire
c'est que pendant l'année scolaire il y
a école
on a vu avec la nouvelle organisation du
bac que
les résultats tombent d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui un très grand nombre des
élèves
n'est pas allé à l'école les deux
derniers mois donc mauvaise réforme a
changé il y avait pas il n'y avait pas
d'élèves pour les profs qui étaient là
et donc
occuper le temps scolaire enfin
s'assurer que le temps scolaire est un
temps utile c'est la première chose à
faire après les affaires de calendrier
scolaire je dis ça amicalement à tous
c'est très compliqué parce que vous avez
l'économie du tourisme
les vacances les locations et évidemment
ce sont des problèmes d'organisation qui
se résolvent pas en claquant
je voudrais revenir à la dimension
politique il y a il y a eu hier une
rencontre à Matignon des représentants
des groupes politiques au Parlement à la
sortie d'ailleurs les sorties avant la
fin l'insoumise n'a-t-il panneau dit
nous on veut pas des rencontres comme ce
métignon on veut un débat au Parlement
au titre de l'article 50-1 la
Constitution il faut que les
parlementaires soient saisi de la
situation vous êtes attachés au droit du
Parlement est-ce que c'est au Parlement
aujourd'hui discuter de ce vous voyez
bien il y a plusieurs niveaux il est
juste qu'il y a un débat au Parlement et
que tout le monde puisse s'exprimer
cette demande il est juste que le
gouvernement s'en occupe et il est juste
que le Président de la République s'en
occupe aussi
parce que le Président de la République
il est en charge non pas des groupes
parlementaires n'ont pas de de la vie du
Parlement il est en charge de la nation
des grands courants de la nation et
c'est tout à fait légitime et normal que
le Président de la République dans sa
responsabilité
j'allais dire grand public grand public
civique opinion civique c'est juste que
le Président de la République s'en
occupe mais il devra en parler il devra
nous parler il est resté assez discret
ces derniers jours il a fait le choix
effectivement de se laisser du temps il
y a une sorte de vide qui est décédée il
y a pas de vide il y a pas de vide il y
a pas de vide mais bien sûr que on sait
bien que d'ici au 14 juillet le
président de la République va s'exprimer
et c'est normal qu'il le fasse
mais c'est normal aussi que nous nous
réfléchissons nous tous le le
bien sûr que les réseaux sociaux
jouaient un très grand rôle dans la
contagion de ces événements
parce qu'ils ont fourni à un climat de
c'est pas pour les uns de désœuvrement
pour les autres d'absence de buts dans
la vie pour les 3e de on sait pas quoi
faire et pour les quatrième aussi un
sentiment de de révolte d'un enfin de on
n'est pas bien dans cette villa tout
cela a fait amalgame et c'est passé en
fait très vite mais vous croyez qu'on
pourra réellement réguler ça l'encadré
parce qu'on voit bien la lutte contre
les Géants du numérique elle est c'est
un combat homérique les souhaits de
régulation ils sont là sur tous les
thèmes racisme antisémitisme
la réalité compliquée ça n'est pas parce
que c'est compliqué qu'il faut rien
faire le le sens de ma vie en tout cas
de mon engagement je sais bien que les
choses sont compliquées et vous le savez
bien et mieux que d'autres
et ça n'est pas parce que les choses
sont compliquées qu'il ne faut rien
faire après ce n'est pas l'annonce des
intentions il ne se passe rien parce que
ça n'avance prenons un exemple
je parlais de du vide de la vie d'un
certain nombre de ces jeunes garçons et
jeunes filles le l'idée d'un service
civique dans lequel ils sont engagés au
début volontairement engagés peut-être
qu'on pourra un jour aller plus loin
dans lequel ils apprennent à servir
servir ça veut dire ça je vais servir
les autres il y a mille fonctions dans
la société qui ne trouvent pas de
réponse et qui pourrait offrir à ces
garçons et à ses filles des raisons de
vivre des raisons de se lever le matin
des raisons d'être fier de même et de ce
qu'ils font et y compris de manière
obligatoire parce que la question
s'était posée elle a été laissée de côté
précisément par exemple
vous savez bien que je défonce cette
idée depuis longtemps alors faut le
faire dans une démarche qui soit une
démarche
compréhensive progressive et c'est
d'ailleurs cela que le gouvernement à
l'esprit mais on a besoin de transformer
des vies vides en vie pleine comment
fait-on et bien on transmet à cela qui
sont notre préoccupation assez assez
jeune fille ces jeunes garçons ont leur
transmet les méthodes pour aller vers
les autres pour servir et pour
rencontrer d'autres pas pour rester
enfermés dans la cité François Bayrou au
vu de la situation du pays est-ce qu'il
faut quelque chose qui ressemble à un
gouvernement d'union nationale à un
gouvernement des mers un gouvernement
des bonnes volontés je sais pas quelle
serait la bonne formule et comment il
faudrait l'appeler mais est-ce qu'il va
falloir aussi un mouvement un mouvement
une modification politique yes ça fait
plusieurs mois qu'on s'interroge sur un
remaniement moi la question se pose
différemment aujourd'hui mais elle se
pose alors vous dites quelque chose qui
est très important la dimension des
problèmes que nous avons devant nous
exigent des démarches politiques
inédites
c'est pas facile parce qu'il y a pas de
partenaire pour l'instant en tout cas
qui manifeste son intention et son
intérêt mais vous voyez bien que les
questions qui se qui se posent là c'est
pas des questions d'affrontements
classiques c'est pas les uns contre les
autres la moitié de la France contre
l'autre moitié c'est plus profond et
plus difficile que ça et si c'est plus
profond et plus difficile il faudra des
démarches politiques plus rassembleuses
dans lesquelles oui on puisse
montrer que les responsables du pays
sont pas seulement des des claniques
sont pas seulement dans dans la
détestation de leur concurrents sont pas
seulement dans le sectarisme
il y a des responsabilités à exercer et
à partager selon moi encore une mission
compliquée mais vous dites compliqué
n'est pas impossible merci beaucoup
François Bayeux d'avoir été sur splato
ce matin dans un instant c'était
Elisabeth Martichoux pour le temps de
l'info d'abord c'est votre météo orange